suite décryptage et analyse on va plus
loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec Marie Roger
Billois présidente du groupe africain
international qui est avec nous en
direct de Yaoundé bonjour Marie Roger
et avec nous également Gautier ribbins
qui chroniqueur international ici mais
ma France 24 bonjour Gauthier
ce mardi aujourd'hui même à Bamako ce
sera finalement jeudi les présidents du
Ghana du Sénégal et du Togo représentant
des États d'Afrique de l'Ouest la CEDEAO
mène une médiation pour faire libérer
les 46 soldats ivoiriens à détenus
depuis le 10 juillet par la junte
malienne Gautier ribinski elle les
accusent d'être des mercenaires faut
répondre l'ONU
bon alors il y a deux possibilités c'est
à dire que en principe ces soldats
ivoiriens sont attachés je dis bien
attachés parce que c'est là-dessus que
porte l'ambiguïté à la minusma
c'est-à-dire la mission et sans unie au
Mali et en principe officiellement ils
sont là pour assurer la sécurité
d'autres soldats en l'occurrence des
soldats allemands sauf que et c'est
là-dessus que ce fond de la jointe
malienne c'est soldat ivoirien ne serait
pas selon la minusma parmi au sein des
effectifs et donc la l'accusation de
finalement d'espionnage de de tromperie
enfin de rourir en tout cas évite avancé
par le Mali rappelant tout de même que
la CEDEAO qui devait justement qui doit
interférer ou intercéder pour une
solution à l'amiable
a dans ses propres rangs la Côte
d'Ivoire et que donc il paraît que la
Côte d'Ivoire dans cette affaire il
apparaît bien qu'elle ne peut qu'être
juge et partie d'un mot si peut-être
élargir la chose c'est que dans ça dans
sa croisade anti coloniale et qui
frappait essentiellement la France la
junte malienne voit probablement dans la
Côte d'Ivoire une sorte d'auxiliaire de
la France et qu'il convient justement de
bordurer voir de temps en temps de s'en
servir comme d'un punching ball un peu
Marie Roger pourquoi la jante malienne
d'après vous ouvre-t-elle ce nouveau
front avec l'un de ses voisins de plus
serait-on tenté de dire
franc c'est quand même l'adversaire
principal et ça pas mal de pays
africains ne comprennent et le soutien
même mais ce qui est nouveau c'est
justement que cette jointe s'en prennent
de manière
ouvertement et et sans la moindre
retenue à des pays qui depuis le début
soutiennent le Mali qui est quand même
en situation de fragilité depuis au
moins deux décennies parce que il faut
voir tout ce qui tous les interventions
que les intervenants je pense dans la
Côte d'Ivoire mais le Niger
ce qui fait sensation ces derniers temps
depuis ce week-end c'était le discours
incendiaire qui a été prononcé du haut
de la tribune des Nations unies par le
Premier ministre par intérim Abdoulaye
Maïga et qui a été accueilli en triomphe
à son retour
au Mali et dans ce discours mais il s'en
prend à tout le monde se dire à l'ONU au
secrétaire général de l'ONU
au président de la en exercice de la
CEDEAO
Sissoko emballo à la Côte d'Ivoire et au
Niger le Niger qui est un pays qui
subit la désorganisation de l'armée
malienne depuis longtemps et puis a
accueilli comme le dit elle-même
lui-même le Niger accueilli pas mal de
militaires des garnisons entières
au Mali et qui essayent voilà
régler le problème sécuritaire avec du
Sahel seul donc on est assez surpris
parce que on connaît les postures vous
savez vous dire que
les nations africaines voilà les
réactions ont été diverses évidemment il
y en a qui applaudissent des deux mains
parce qu'ils disent oui que
l'émancipation c'est d'abord par le
verbe et la parole des complexée mais
une fois qu'on a dit ça le Mali se
retrouve avec un problème et on ne voit
même pas ce qu'il a dit de particulier
justement pour illustrer ce que vous
dites et qu'on comprenne bien on va
écouter un extrait qui concerne
justement la France dans ce qu'a dit le
Premier ministre Abdoulaye Maïga
nos autorités françaises profondément
anti française
pour avoir régné les valeurs morales
universelles et trahit le lourd héritage
des philosophes des Lumières
se sont transformés en une jante au
service de l'obscurantisme on va
retourner voir Marie Roger dans un
instant mais gauthierry binsky il
parlait de jantes françaises il retourne
à l'accusation finalement d'un pouvoir
qui serait illégitime en France
c'est vraiment un discours jusqu'au
boutiste qui a stupéfié il faut le dire
ce qu'il a entendu samedi oui c'était
d'une de grande violence parce que il a
même asséné à trois reprises il a répété
des phrases qui étaient particulièrement
violentes à l'égard de la France mais
vous savez j'en viens j'ai envie de dire
quand on parle de jeunes vous souvenez
de cette fameuse réplique de Vladimir
Poutine algobiden qu'il avait accusé
d'être un tueur et écouter il avait dit
à l'époque c'était encore une forme de
détente il avait dit c'est celui qui en
parle qui est un tueur mais là c'est un
petit peu la même chose
Abdoulaye Maya dit la France est une
jante c'est évidemment le Mali qui en
étude mais ce qui est intéressant parce
que ce que disait Marie Roger c'est
effectivement l'accueil triomphale qui
lui a été réservé en rentrant à Bamako
et là il y a quelque chose
de diablement intéressant parce que si
vous voulez il me semble
quel que soit j'insiste là-dessus quel
que soit les responsabilités et le
mauvais ouvrage de la France de par son
colonialisme il me semble qu'on est
encore pour la gente malienne dans une
forme de complexe coloniale qui fait que
la France est rendue à tort ou à raison
mais responsable de tous les mots et
effectivement quand monsieur m'accusé la
France d'être parti d'avoir quitté le
Mali
contradictoires c'est à dire qu'il a
accusé la France d'être parti mais en
même temps c'est le jeu et ensuite de
lui avoir tiré dans le dos dit-il dans
le dos et ensuite d'avoir justement
abandonner la chose juste d'un mot ce
qui me paraît important justement c'est
cette abcès de fixation sur l'ancienne
puissance coloniale alors que
précisément monsieur Maïga s'est employé
a dédouané de toute mauvaise pensée de
toutes mauvaises intentions par exemple
les Russes et donc là il y a si vous
voulez la sortie et pourquoi pas à juste
titre de la tutelle d'un ancien colon
d'un ancien pays de de colonisation pour
se ranger vers une autre colonisation et
c'est ça qui qui bloque c'est ça qui
c'est pas la violence en elle-même du
discours contre la France c'est sa
naïveté par rapport à d'autres
puissances éventuellement tutélaire
c'est l'exact inverse un du discours
d'Emmanuel Macron Marie Roger qui trois
jours plus tôt à cette même tribune de
l'ONU dénonçait le néocolonialisme russe
et d'ailleurs en appelait à ces nouveaux
non alignés à choisir leur camp et à ne
pas se reconnaître dans le projet de la
Russie qui selon lui était avant tout de
redéfinir les frontières de manière
arbitraire ce qu'a dit le Premier
ministre malien à la tribune samedi ça a
tout de même vous dit qu'il a été
acclamé à son retour au Mali ça tout de
même choqué jusque dans les rangs de
l'opposition malienne
absolument moi je dirais que lorsqu'on
regarde les réactions de plus près
vraiment j'ai passé du temps à voir et
ça me faire une idée alors qu'est-ce que
les Africains pensent je dirais la
plupart sont d'abord gênés
parce que même si soutiennent un peu
cette posture
anti impérialiste et qui est un peu le
bouclier de cette crainte militaire au
passage Renault par le soir de jeunes il
y a rien qui les énervent plus que quand
on les qualifie de jeunes et de coucher
ce sont des faits mais c'est des faits
qui n'arrivent pas à accepter mais donc
il est la plupart des gens sont gênés
beaucoup estiment que oui il faut dire
les choses on a comparé à Sainte parade
par exemple on savait que ça me
décrochait des flèches des flèches sans
versées dans les instructures tribuales
voilà et on lui a reproché également on
se dit bon parler certes mais pour dire
quoi il y avait des choses importantes à
soutenir par exemple lorsque
demande un siège au conseil de pour
l'Afrique au Conseil de sécurité voilà
le Mali aurait pu soutenir ça le Mali
aussi a
accusé la France
pour rendre du mois d'août
auprès du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
en disant que la France
soutenait financée et donner des armes
au terrorisme alors tout le monde se dit
va donner des preuves parce qu'ils ont
dit nous avons des preuves on a attendu
ça et donc même du côté je pense
l'ancien Premier ministre un ancien
Premier ministre malien qui a dit bon il
salue le fait que le Mali le Premier
ministre par intérim qui parlait au nom
du Mali a réaffermir son attachement au
respect des droits de l'homme et aussi
au retour à l'ordre conditionnel mais
ils se disent tomberiqueuse à quoi ça
rime lorsqu'on pense que le Mali est
quand même le grand malade de la de
région et qu'il a besoin de ses alliés
on ne peut pas se brouiller avec
on se demande quel avantage et
dire être flatter son ego et l'ego de je
dirais
superficiel et épidermique de certains
mais parce que derrière le Niger a déjà
annoncé qui le suspendait le transit des
prêtres des produits pétroliers vers le
Mali voilà déjà des conséquences
concrètes c'est à dire que le Mali il va
peut-être échapper à échapper aux
censions de la CEDEAO mais voilà il y
aura sans doute des représailles
individuels la Côte d'Ivoire va encore
rien dit parce que bon maintenant ils
vont revenir pour la libération pour
négocier la libération des 46 militaires
ivoiriens mais la Côte d'Ivoire a
beaucoup de
Dardes de flèches dans son arc contre le
Mali par exemple auquel
l'électricité par exemple le commerce
par de du port ivoirien vers le Mali etc
etc donc on se demande à quoi ça sert ce
genre de diatribles si le lendemain on
se retrouve
avec plus de problèmes qu'auparavant
on va passer à l'autre sujet de
l'actualité c'est un score la soviétique
qui se profile ça ne s'invente pas
d'ailleurs les référendums
d'autodétermination imposées aux régions
ukrainiennes devraient sans surprise
donner vainqueur le rattachement à la
Russie voici comment Vladimir Poutine
justifie ses scrutin un motif
humanitaire écouté
le sauvetage des populations surtout ces
territoires dans lesquels se tient le
référendum
est au premier plan et au centre de
l'attention de notre société et de tout
le pays
il avait usé il faut le rappeler par une
méthode c'était en osseti du Sud et en a
quasi deux régions géorgiennes dans
lesquelles les Russes avaient
abondamment distribué les passeports
avant de décréter un motif humanitaire
pour exiger alors non pas à l'époque le
rattachement mais l'indépendance de
l'ossetti du Sud en l'occurrence
oui rattachement de la quasi voilà alors
souvenez-vous aussi c'est exact c'était
ça consistait à tailler en pièces le
territoire géorgien ou d'ailleurs il
faut remarquer qu'aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de Russes se réfugient
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont dans la dans
la région du Caucase ce qui peut même
mettre en difficulté l'étagère et
surtout qu'il l'agace parce que les la
direction géorgienne dit écoutez c'est
bien beau que vous refusiez de vous
battre aujourd'hui mais c'était avant
aussi qu'il fallait le faire pour nous
défendre bref je vais faire la
parenthèse ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est que si vous voulez la la
justification
de que donne Vladimir Poutine quasiment
personne n'en est dupe et que encore une
fois pardonnez-moi je vais répéter ce
que je dis souvent il y a dans les mots
de Vladimir Poutine souvent
la trace la volonté d'une provocation et
en même temps d'une jubilation à
l'endroit de l'Occident et des supposés
valeurs en tout cas c'est ce qu'il dit
lui de l'Occident vous voyez vous vous
faites beaucoup vous tenez énormément
des procédures référendaires électorales
ben écoutez si ça vous chante moi je
peux faire la même chose mais ça n'a
aucun intérêt aucun impact c'est si vrai
qu'on a appris ce soir parce que j'étais
étonné qu'il soit pas là une si tu veux
si vous voulez une oui un arrêtage de
comment dirais-je de l'extrême droite un
florigel de l'extrême droite européenne
qui joue effectivement là les imbéciles
inutiles totalement ils sont là pour
dire tout se passe bien les observateurs
alors voilà et on avait eu la même chose
la dernière fois et là c'est pareil
c'est à dire que contrairement à ce
qu'il professe lorsqu'ils sont en Europe
en Occident de leur pays là ils
commencent ça consiste à dire oui c'est
une consultation parfaitement réglée
réglementaire légitime et tout va bien
voilà là aussi c'est une manière de dire
à l'Occident et eux sont complices mais
bon dieu ils n'en ont pas grand chose
oui c'est de oui mais je crois que c'est
pour mieux montrer qu'il est ridiculise
et que précisément l'Occident ne peut
pas se gargariser selon lui de mettre en
application ce type de procédure parce
que lui les mépr et finalement les
traites en les appliquant il les traite
comme quelque chose de totalement
négligeable c'est un engrenage infernal
qui est en oeuvre là Marie Roger une
fois ces territoires un décrétérus
Moscou trouvera prétexte d'user de tous
les moyens sur le terrain
oui certainement c'est ça le plan mais
je crois qu'il y a une chose qui a
changé depuis le début de ce conflit
c'est que
fait moins peur
je me souviens que j'ai dit sur ce
plateau que c'est la russieuse
les pays occidentaux étaient à se
demander qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans la
tête de Poutine etc mais maintenant même
cet argument nucléaire à l'air
démonétisée et c'est vrai qu'il faut
faire attention tout est possible mais
on n'a pas l'impression que le fait
d'avoir grandi à nouveau cet arbre pour
la dernière fois va affaiblir le camp
occidental ou du courage je crois pas du
tout et on le voit dans les pays comme
en Allemagne ou maintenant ils sont
déterminés à livrer encore je sais pas
quel tank n'est-ce pas les armes encore
plus sophistiquées
le sexe le monde enfin disons qu'on
pense que la Russie peut perdre la
guerre ça change tout je dirais que
voilà donc il le sait et
il va essayer son bateau et tous tout ça
ça fait partie c'est qu'on veut personne
va reconnaître l'annexion bon mais il
essaye on dirait quelques conséquences
qui vont dans le sens de la victoire qui
le continue à espérer vraiment Gautier
le Leclerc brandit par la Russie ne fait
plus aussi peur aujourd'hui c'est vrai
on l'a vu dans les réactions beaucoup et
ont vu plutôt un affaiblissement une
fois que de l'affaiblissement des Russes
qu'une menace potentielle à l'horizon et
puis aussi cette erreur qu'on fait c'est
par le Crémat ce qui n'est habituel oui
sur la sur la mobilisation oui alors
deux choses c'est vrai rapidement c'est
que moi je ne serai pas aussi
triomphaliste je crois même que
professer un tel triomphalisme
c'est-à-dire dire c'est bien la preuve
que le régime russe est affaibli c'est
quelque chose de dangereux c'est quelque
chose de dangereux parce que dans
l'historiographie et même j'allais dire
dans la cosmogonie russe il y a l'idée
que l'on n'est jamais aussi fort que
lorsqu'on a le dos au mur et qu'on est
vraiment acculé je donne un seul qui est
connu de tout le monde c'est ce qui est
arrivé aux troupes françaises de
Napoléon c'est à dire une ville de
Moscou
par les rues ce même pour se défendre et
là il y a quelque chose de très fort la
fameuse guerre patriotique contre le
nazisme est aussi pensé et pour le coup
c'était vrai comme une résistance du
dernier recours tout simplement parce
que Staline avait totalement coupé les
têtes au sens prix figuré et propre de
l'armée soviétique de sorte qu'elle
n'était pas à même de combattre les
nazis vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est à chaque fois quand on est au bord
du précipice ça c'est très très fort
dans y compris chez les militaires
russes c'est là qu'on est le meilleur et
c'est pour ça que je fais attention si
vous voulez à ce triomphalisme je
préfère qu'il y ait effectivement des
avancées militaires
ukrainiennes plutôt que de dire c'est
fini exclure un usage non irraisonné de
la force nucléaire totalement voilà
irraisonné de la même manière que cette
campagne est irraisonnée sur les sur les
l'immobilisation le Kremlin qu'on fasse
une erreur oui si ce n'est que au fond
on peut se dire que puisque le le
porte-parole administration
présidentielle et Valentine Mathieu qui
qui est à la Chambre haute et bien
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils servent en
quelque sorte le bon roi Vladimir le bon
roi Vladimir qui parfois n'est pas au
courant de ce qui se passe et ils disent
mon roi regardez regardez ça n'est pas
vos fils de Russie ne sont pas là pour
trahir ils sont là pour dire nous
voulons la justice rendez-leur justice
disent-ils à vlaïre Poutine et puis un
seul de ses fils de vos fils de vous
manquera pour écraser qui retrouve sa
ligne directe d'une certaine manière
directe merci gauthierry binsky merci
Marie Roger Billaud à c’était ton va
plus loin on se retrouve dans moins de 3
minutes pour un nouveau journal rester
avec nous
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de politique